dank die fdp fraktion hat irgend dieser
nächsten legislatur 82 abgeordnete 24
neue sind darunter und einen von ihnen
kann ich jetzt hier bei mir begrüßen das
ist gary tui sie ist für die fdp
fraktion über die bayerische landesliste
in den bundestag eingezogen wo ihm ein
kollege hat gerade seine
gesprächspartnerinnen und partner auch
gefragt wie wie in ihre partei gekommen
sind jetzt möchte sie auch gleich fragen
tatsächlich wie sind sie denn zur afg
gekommen weil tatsächlich sind sie so
etwas wie eine spätstarterin in der
politik auf ihren beruflichen
hintergrund kommen wir vielleicht also
wie sind sie dazu gekommen ich bin
tatsächlich eine spätstarterin das gilt
aber für viele von uns in der partei
weil wir die meisten von uns aus
normalen bürgerlichen berufen kommen und
erst durch unzufriedenheit mit der
politischen situation so politik
gekommen sind das gilt auch für mich ich
war insbesondere mit der
presseberichterstattung nicht immer
einverstanden mit der einengung des
meinungsspektrums sowie ist sie
wahrgenommen habe von mir ist
aufgefallen dass der wohlstand im land
doch gar nicht so üppig ist wie immer
dargestellt wird also dass wir gar nicht
im westen in deutschland an der zeiten
leben und daran würde ich gerne was
ändern sie waren muss man sagen eine sie
war die erste frau in einem vorstand von
daimler benz
bei leo kirch beispielsweise auf und
haben noch einige andere stationen in
ihrem beruflichen leben gehabt
tatsächlich die haben gesagt sie haben
auch gesehen wie bernd lucke damals und
hans olaf henkel nicht gerecht behandelt
wurden allerdings genau sind diese
beiden herren ja gar nicht mehr in der
afg also wie sehen sie denn die
veränderung der afd die sich in den
letzten jahren vollzogen hat ich sehe
dass wir eine reihe von professoren
verloren haben dass wir viele normale
handwerker gewonnen haben ich finde
diesen wandel gar nicht so schlecht und
ich sehe auch nicht diese recht
verschiebung also so weit rechts wie wir
immer gesagt werden dass wir uns
verschieben da müssten am anderen ende
schon wieder links raus kommen ich sehe
das nicht also ich sehe schon dass wir
eine relativ gemischter mit einem
breiten bürgerlichen spektrums selber
ordne mich der mitte zu und bin sowohl
liberal als auch sozial engagiert
jetzt ist unter ihren neuen
fraktionskollegen aber trotzdem sind
beispielsweise solche abgeordnete wie
hannes knaup der soldat war und vom
militärischen abschirmdienst der
bundeswehr als extremist eingestuft
worden ist und derzeit keine uniformen
tragen darf er ist einer ihrer
fraktionskollegen jetzt wie gehen sie
damit um ich kann spezielle nicht sagen
also ich kenne ihn nur sehr flüchtig von
den ersten fazit zur und sitzungen ich
kann mir darüber kein urteil erlauben
mal war es wird viel über uns gesagt
dass wir extremistische werden was ich
nicht bestätigt sehe ich kenne ja die
partie relativ gut in relativ großem
umfang auch und ich finde das einfach
nicht wieder man hat auch von einenkel
gesagt und von der locke gesagt dass die
rechtsextremistisch wären was absurd war
bei diesem speziellen fall tatsächlich
sagt es jetzt eine der
sicherheitsdienste doch ich habe das
verstanden schon also ich kann das nicht
beurteilen weil ich gehe immer davon aus
dass das auch nicht so gerechtfertigt
ist in ihrer fraktion in der afg
generell gibt es wenige frauen da hat
sich auch jetzt seien frauen anteil von
13 prozent warum gehen so wenige frauen
jetzt gerade in die afg was ist ihre
beobachtung das weiß ich nicht aber wir
werden ja auch von weniger frauen als
männern gewählt wahrscheinlich werden
wir im außenbild zu martialisch oder
dargestellt was wir im inneren will ich
ja gar nicht sind bei uns haben die
frauen die dabei sind die gute arbeit
macht und absolut gleichberechtigte
chancen da muss ich tatsächlich fragen
es gibt die für das verlangen der fdp
fraktion nicht mehr neben der afg
fraktion zu sitzen und ein grund der
genannt wird das können sie jetzt noch
nicht beurteilen sie sind der neue up
oder ein grund der von auch fdp frauen
genannt wird dass es von seiten der afg
gerade von seiten der männer auf
bemerkungen in richtung der fdp gab weil
die sie nicht als angenehm empfunden
haben will ich es mal ausdrücken ich
will sie einfach fragen wie werden sie
denn auf den ton auch im parlament auch
in ihrer eigenen fraktion achten
also ich gehe davon aus dass wir höflich
miteinander umgehen aber ich muss sagen
ich hab auch nichts anderes bisher
erlebt natürlich gibt es sehr harte
sache auseinandersetzung da prallen die
meinungen zum teil sehr heftig
aufeinander aber dafür sind wir ja auch
da dass wir die konzepte ausdiskutieren
widersprechende meinungen aus
diskutieren am ende ein vernünftiges
konzept häusern an der sitzung
tatsächlich auch nicht gemeint hat ja
wolfgang schäuble auch in seiner rede
zu sagen der ton wie man auch unter den
abgeordneten miteinander umgeht
dazu kann ich zu wenig sagen also ich
gehe davon aus dass unsere abgeordneten
über höflich sind und durch meine man
darf es auch nicht als rechtsempfinden
wenn man als frauen freundlich
angelächelt wird das finde ich ziemlich
albern diese äußerung sind ja auch schon
gefallen vielen dank gary tue alles für
die afg fraktion dass sie hier zu mir
gekommen sind